the other story this week is that there
was this big women's 500 yard freestyle
swimming championship
and it was one
it was won
by a biological male by the name of leah
thomas
okay this is someone who was something
like 450th in men's swimming who decided
to transition and
you know my position on this if an adult
wants to do anything with their life
live how they wish change their name
wear whatever they want that's fine once
you're an adult it's a different thing
when you're a kid but in essence leah
thomas is a biological male
with biological male genitals i will
leave it at that the girls are now
seeing that in the locker room who won
first place but desantis he ain't
putting up with that either
if you look at what the ncaa has done
by allowing basically men to compete in
women's athletics in this case the
swimming you had the number one woman
who finished was from sarasota
eminent she won the silver medal she's
been an absolute superstar her whole
career and she had the fastest time
of any woman in college athletics now
the ncaa
is basically taking efforts to destroy
women's athletics they're trying to
undermine the integrity of the
competition and they're crowning
somebody else uh the woman's champion
and we think that's wrong and so in
florida i'm going to be
late as this is a floridian who i think
deserves to be recognized you know we're
going to be doing a proclamation
saying
that emma is the best female swimmer in
the 500 meter freestyle because she
earned that and we need to stop allowing
organizations like the ncaa to
perpetuate frauds on the public and
that's exactly what they're doing they
are putting ideology ahead of
opportunity for women out
guys what do i say every single day now
when someone's telling the truth you
know they're telling the truth and
because we live in such a time of lies
it's actually
a uh it's a relief it's a release off
your chest isn't it when you hear
someone tell the truth and say the thing
that we all know that is obvious even
though most people won't say it and not
only is he saying it he is a man of his
word because he did release the
proclamation and good for emma good for
emma emma if you're watching you are the
best 500 swimmer in in the state of
florida maybe in the country i don't
know you want to come on the show we'll
talk about it
what can i do for you i'd love to help
you out here's an image in case you're
just unsure of this story i know it's
been getting a lot of coverage but first
here's an image after the race so that's
leah thomas on the left that's emma's
was it watson was it emma watson no not
watson
um
emma wyant sorry emma wine emma watson
is in uh harry potter or something
different emma uh but okay so there's
leah thomas the supposed winner women's
winner of this thing
uh and there's of course uh emma in the
middle there's the third place finisher
on the right do you see do you think
maybe there's a biological problem am i
a bigot or a racist or a nazi for saying
that maybe there's a biological problem
and if you want to see how this is all
connected to the media and how they lie
about everything and push a narrative
nbc news covered this story
and look at the image that they put up
this is actually this is really really
extraordinary these are the same people
who are constantly
constantly telling you that everything
people are exactly the same the image on
the left right there is the image that
nbc news used on their report you can
see it is heavily airbrushed to take
away a lot of the male features the
strong features of the nose and the eyes
and the mouth i mean look what they did
there that looks like it's instagram
airbrushed which girls use on instagram
to usually make their eyes look bigger
and their skin's softer and everything
else the image on the right is the
unedited image so nbc news ran this
story and decided for the narrative of
the story we are going to make
the guy
the woman with a penis who won first
place we are going to make he or she
whatever
you want to say
in this case i'm going to say he and if
they're going to boot me off youtube
it's ridiculous but a guy should not be
winning a woman's uh a woman's swimming
race it's just as simple as that and
that has nothing to do with bigotry and
hatred and you all know it including you
you weirdo youtube censors who are
watching this right now just waiting and
you freaks of media matters one more
time put it up on the image one more
time so just know that that nvc put that
image up on the left if they were honest
if nbc was honest if journalists were
honest would they be airbrushing the
image to make him look more like a her
i think not